As we get older,
we're introduced to larger and larger numbers.
The first unaccounted,
10 then 20 then maybe a hundred then we learn about a thousand and thousands and
a million and a billion and a trillion,
but it kind of stops there for most people.
I mean the number line certainly doesn't stop there,
but we don't really use numbers higher than a Trulia and all that.
Often at a personal level anyway,
as our civilization has grown,
we've had need of higher numbers in a trillion to contemplate or universe.
So maybe you wondered what comes after a trillion will the answer to that
question,
believe it or not,
as a trillion in one pass,
999 trillion,
999 billion,
999,999,999 we reached one quadrillion with five groups of Zeros and four groups
of zero is more than a thousand.
Just like a quadrilateral has four sides add three more zeros and we get a
quintillion than a sex Tilian.
Then a septillion than octillion than non alien in a one followed by 33 Zeros
and the deck Elian.
They sound like difficult names.
It really all it takes is the ability to count.
And Len Len has a unique and beautiful ability to make simple things seem very
complicated.
For example,
in Septillion Septum means just seven in Latin in septillion has seven more sets
of Zeros and a thousand in Quinta Kilian,
which has 15 more sets of Zeros in 1000 Quinn deck,
I'm just means 15 to put these numbers to use the Milky Way galaxy is about a
quintillion kilometers long.
That's 600 quadrillion miles.
There were about one octillion Adams and the average human body,
10 billion years,
it's 315 quadrillion seconds long and the earth weighs about six septillion
kilograms.
That's 13 octillion pounds.
Although the Latin numbers don't write with us through all of our numbers and
our adventure and the number line,
what would be 10 duo trigon trillion,
a thousand followed by 96 zeros is just called it Google.
So what's the biggest number called?
Well,
that's an impossible question.
Take any of them where you can think of and you can add one to it.
Mathematicians call this concept of endlessness on the number line,
infinity,
which is also a Latin word from infinitum for videos or mathematics,
science,
and much more.
I would invite you to check out my channel and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.